[Music]
we all love long-running cartoons with
our favorite characters but some of
these shows have been around way too
long you won't believe how long number
one has been on the air if you're a
cartoon fan like we are hit that
subscribe button to catch all of our
latest videos on cartoons and more now
here at teen cartoons that lasted way
too long
South Park South Park has made us laugh
for over 20 years Matt Stone and Trey
Parker have created controversial
hilarious and downright strange episodes
for two decades but it's got to be hard
to come up with new ideas on every
episode for 20 years many of us have
heard of the phrase jumped the shark
this happens when a long-running TV show
has run out of ideas so they come up
with outlandish events in a desperate
attempt to top all the previous episodes
they did it in happy days when Fonzie
literally jumped over a shark in water
skis so a South Park jumped the shark
our consensus is yes many times one of
the most ridiculous jumped the shark
episodes was lice Capades in this
episode we are introduced to a colony of
family loving lice living in Klein
Harris's hair the plot is like that of
every apocalyptic disaster movie while
making a bizarre statement about our
global impact on the planet so they are
not only making us watch 22 minutes of
lice carnage they are comparing us to
parasites but who can blame them it was
their 156 episode although South Park
had a multitude of laugh-out-loud funny
episodes that changed pop culture and
poked fun at just about everyone if they
probably should have stopped at life's
Capades
Family Guy with 16 seasons and 300
episodes Family Guy is the second
longest running show on Fox
this show has covered everything from
time travel to a baby on steroids but
with that many seasons and episodes one
may start to wonder our fans tired of
the same characters week after week for
19 years
nope they are going to keep turning
these babies as long as possible but
you've got to wonder how they have any
more to talk about after 300 episodes
the premise of the show is certainly
nothing new an attractive woman is
married to an oafish buffoon they have a
few adorable oddball children and a dog
who can talk tale as old as time right
from all in the family to married with
children to the
Simpsons this family-based situation
comedy is predictable but so relatable
that must be why the show is successful
not to mention the fact that it's loaded
with a bunch of hilariously
inappropriate jokes so how long will
Family Guy continue to run one thing is
certain Seth MacFarlane has created a
show that keeps viewers coming back week
after week to see what kinds of
shenanigans Peter Griffin and his family
are getting into Arthur PBS's Arthur
features an aardvark who wears glasses
and shows kids how to deal with the
challenges of childhood like homework
teachers and bullies Arthur has
presented 21 seasons and a total of 235
episodes it doesn't seem to be slowing
down anytime soon it originally started
as a bedtime story which author Mark
Brown told his children one night his
son Toland requested a story about a
weird animal mark came up with a beef
speckled aardvark and Arthur was born
for 22 years this heartwarming show has
inspired children and taught them how to
deal with obstacles we don't see
anything wrong with that we are
impressed that the writing staff has
found this many subjects to discuss in
their show's week after week and we
never get tired of hearing the show's
theme song believe in yourself by Ziggy
Marley it's so popular it's been covered
by the Backstreet Boys chance the rapper
and the wife left John Arthur has won
seven Emmys and a Peabody Award for its
easygoing attitude embracing
intelligence and encouragement of
self-empowerment and further learning
for children everywhere while this show
has been on the air for a long time we
have to say we hope it sticks around for
a while longer fairly odd parents fairly
oddparents is truly the Lazarus of TV
shows
meaning it's been resurrected from the
dead a lot five times to be exact
it has almost as many lives as Catman in
an interview with the show creator Butch
Hartman he said Fairly OddParents has
been canceled five times we've had five
wrap parties and every time we have a
wrap party
like a week after the wrap party they go
you know what we're gonna bring it back
and I was like okay I've never thought
it was ever going to go away while the
show has been making kids and adults
laugh for ten seasons
some fans agreed that it has gone on for
way too long eventually they are bound
to run out of fairy jokes the word
around fairy town is that fans were
love with season 10 one fan even said it
started off as charming funny and
overall entertaining but now it depends
on overuse plots jokes and characters
they had a good run with a lot of ups
and downs fans want to remember it as a
funny show that made them laugh as kids
time to retire to me we wish you the
best Aqua Teen Hunger Force Aqua Teen
Hunger Force was the longest-running
original series in the history of Adult
Swim's cartoon shows it was also the
sixth long-running animated show in the
United States the top five
longest-running shows in American TV are
the Simpsons Arthur South Park king of
the hill and SpongeBob SquarePants Aqua
Teen Hunger Force comes in behind these
heavy hitters at number six it's
inappropriate humor and oddball
characters had been a staple for Adult
Swim fans for 11 seasons when describing
the show
co-creator dave willis said there's no
story to it they're just entertaining
characters they're obnoxious this show
didn't really follow traditional plot or
story lines either it's as if the
writers just jotted down notes on a
cocktail napkin while under the
influence of a particular herbal
supplement and poof it became a show
many of the episodes seemed to be the
result of a strange dare where they
pushed the envelope just to see what
they can get away with of course this
can't go on forever did you see the one
with the weird red cat who looks like
Abraham Lincoln and was trying to peddle
sausage links to the at-home audience
maybe you guys should have put down the
bong years ago spongebob squarepants if
you can't answer the question who lives
in a pineapple under the sea then you
have been living under a rock for the
last 19 years spongebob squarepants
Nickelodeon's prime time and the
award-winning and wildly popular cartoon
follows a naive and curious yellow
sponge around an underwater sea town by
the name of bikini bottom Patrick
SpongeBob's half-witted but loyal
companion a squirrel and an old-timey
diving suit named Sandy Cheeks and a
disgruntled hipster squid named
Squidward are among the group of fun sea
characters that fans keep coming back to
see week after week this show was
actually created by a marine biologist
named Stephen Hillenburg
it's hard to say how he passed any of
the tests to get his degree
if he thinks kitchen sponges live in
pineapples under the sea
squirrels can live in a dome underwater
indefinitely
see creatures love eating at fast food
restaurants but he did get kids excited
about ocean life with all the years of
adventure Spongebob and his friends have
already had it's hard to figure out how
they can keep coming up with new
material maybe the show is ready to
retire soon but not as long as nautical
nonsense is something you wish clearance
there are some shows that even with
short runs lasted way too long
Cartoon Network's Clarence is one of
those shows Clarence peaches fourth
grade characters with box shaped heads
hot pink skin and hardcore unibrow let's
just say the show's humor is an acquired
taste the characters are gross weird and
we're not sure what is going on here the
creator of the show
Skyler Page was fired in 2014 due to
allegations of misconduct from one of
the staff of the show maybe that was a
sign that the show was doomed from the
beginning
even though Skyler page was the original
voice of clearance in the show Cartoon
Network replaced him and went on to make
many more episodes but was that a good
idea
many young critics say no like this 12
year old cartoon connoisseur who said
Clarence is the most stupid show I have
ever watched when the 12 year old kids
turn against you then you know you've
got a problem while Clarence didn't run
near as long as some of the other
animated shows on this list we feel it
still lasted way too long no hard
feelings Clarence fans and creators it
just wasn't our pinata full of candy
king of the hill many of the older fans
remember king of the hill creator Mike
judge for his MTV hit show beavis and
butt-head beavis and butt-head was a
STONER favorite that featured two dirty
minded teenagers who commented on music
videos and slap each other around Mike
judges next creation king of the hill
centered on the lives of a middle-class
family living in Texas the show did
really well in its sunday night slot
Time magazine even called it one of the
100 greatest television shows ever king
of the hill had a great 13 season run
producing a total of two hundred and
fifty-nine episodes before it was
cancelled in 2009 but it was reported in
the summer of last year that Fox was
entertaining the possibility of bringing
the show back to the small screen Fox
Television Group Chairman Dana Walden
told the press
we had a very preliminary conversation
given what's going on in the country I
think they had a point of view about how
those characters would respond it
certainly does make for interesting
television but is the
rise country of 2018 ready for a king of
the hill reboots reboots have become
pretty popular lately we'll just have to
wait and see
Phineas and Ferb Phineas and Ferb is a
show that deals with kids struggle with
boredom during summer vacation in the
show the main characters Phineas and
Ferb counters summer time by turning the
backyard into a hot spot for backyard
inventions and shenanigans phineas his
sister is always trying to catch them in
the act so she can tattle on him to
their mother but it's usually
unsuccessful the show's theme song even
ends with phineas to sister yelling mama
Phineas and Ferb are making a title
sequence it's pretty cute we have to
admit these two are clever and
compelling to watch but after two
hundred and twenty two episodes maybe
it's time these boys go back to school
for the fall we'll always remember the
times Phineas and Ferb built a towering
rollercoaster in the backyard in the
very first episode and there was a Star
Wars Episode in season four made the
Ferb be with you ah summer memories but
alas the show was cancelled in 2015
summer can't last forever kids for all
you super fans out there phineas and
Ferb's zany backyard adventures continue
to stream on Netflix do you think this
show lasted too long or not long enough
leave a comment telling us what you
think The Simpsons
back in December 1989 a little animated
show called
The Simpsons premiered it featured a
warm-hearted doughnut and beer loving
dopey father named Homer Simpson his
blue haired loving wife Marge a
troublemaker son Bart a bookish activist
and saxophone player daughter Lisa and a
pacifier sucking baby who always falls
down Maggie
nobody knew it then but this show would
become the longest-running animated show
in the history of American television
with over 600 episodes in fact the
Simpsons became one of only two
television shows to air 600's ODEs ever
the other show to hold that honor with
CBS's Gunsmoke which ended in 1975 the
six hundredth episode was called
treehouse of horror 27 and they really
pulled out all the stops for this one
they even had a virtual reality couch
gag in the opening sequence which could
be viewed through Google Goggles
with custom-made branded goggles
produced for the events
the animated show the characters never
age that means this show could go on and
on forever and ever and ever we admit we
wouldn't mind if it did the Simpsons
have become a part of our American
culture they're as American as baseball
and apple pie let's face it this show
will probably outlive us all
and that's it for 10 cartoons that
lasted way too long
be sure to check out our other videos
for more see you next time
[Music]